bien entendu mes chers collègues le
secteur des télécoms est en pleine
mutation et nous sommes évidemment
impatient d'avoir votre avis sur le
contexte que nous sommes en train de
vivre
qu'il s'agisse de l'arrivée du nouvel
opérateur ou de la quatrième licence sur
le marché de la téléphonie mobile avec
des conséquences qu'on voit apparaître
que les uns et les autres avaient
annoncé d'ailleurs c'est à dire les
trois fresques les trois opérateurs
précédent d'autre part l'arrivée de ce
nouvel opérateur vous avez un contrat
d'itinérance avec free
une arrivée qui entraîne évidemment une
reconfiguration du modèle économique du
secteur avec la clé des des
questionnements de moyen et long termes
sur ses implications sociales et en
particulier sur la stratégie
industrielle et commerciale dans le
domaine des télécoms
pour faire court je vous lève évoqué
tout à l'heure dans mon bureau monsieur
le président est-ce qu'on n'a pas choisi
le consommateur au détriment de l'emploi
et eux et à long terme
c'est tout le problème en tous les cas
de cette arrivée sur l'autel de la
concurrence sont mesurés à moi je
voudrais mon sentiment sans mesurer les
effets à moyen et long termes sur la
couverture du territoire mon cher
président sur la rigueur
pardon le déploiement de la fibre et le
grec possibilités d'investissement qu'il
s'agisse également la modernisation des
réseaux à la fois fixe
je sais que
j'y travaillais avec le déploiement
aussi progressif mais trop lents sans
doute aux goûts de nos collègues de la
fibre optique est également 1,2 je
dirais de la couverture en téléphonie
mobile et surtout avec l'arrivée du
réseau 4g quatrième génération dont
l'entrée en service est prévue à la fin
de l'année sur cette question des
réseaux sans doute évoquerez vous pour
évacuer d'entrée le bug qui s'est
produit qui a affecté le réseau votre
réseau de téléphonie mobile au niveau
national sur lequel d'ailleurs je crois
que vous aviez réalisé un audit
je sais pas vous ne direz de mots
là-dessus mais je voudrais simplement
mes chers collègues vous dire que je
suis un peu inquiet de la fragilité de
la société que nous nous sommes donnés
je pense à tous les raisons que ce soit
les télécommunications que ce soit les
réseaux d'électricité
que ce soit les réseaux de transport que
ce soit les réseaux d'eau potable
autrement dit tous les réseaux auxquels
au quotidien nous nous sommes
utilisateurs et qu'une seule panne que
ce soit dans dans le soft ou dans le
armes nous met dans une situation et qui
déstabilise économiquement certaines
régions quand ça se produit
c'est en tous les cas une réflexion que
je me pose depuis un certain temps sur
la fragilité de notre société à
l'arrivée des technologies dites
nouvelles ou pas d'ailleurs mais en tous
les cas de la fragilité que nous avons
et sur lequel je ne vois pas très bien
les modes de défense enfin nous pourrons
aborder une phase peut-être plus
prospective avec votre vision de
l'avenir du groupe dans le contexte
européen et international on vous preuve
en vous prête des projets de
rapprochement avec votre homologue
allemand le deutsche telekom très
puissant en inde ayant même niveau sans
doute que vous à peu près
salle 2 ça ne donne deux athlètes de
haut niveau qui pourrait avoir une
médaille d'or au niveau national au
niveau international dans le contexte de
joseph est sans doute ya des barrières
un saut de haies ou d'obstacles à
franchir avant d'y arriver mais c'est
peut-être aussi une stratégie au niveau
international est ce que c'est une
stratégie offensive ou une stratégie
défensive au niveau européen qui est
derrière ce projet de rapprochement mais
sur vue après avoir évoqué tous ces
sujets je suis persuadé que nos
collègues auront beaucoup d'autres
questions et je peux simplement la
parole à mon homologue raymond vall
concernant la commission développement
durable
merci président roule donc monsieur le
président vous le dire vous êtes ici
dont devant deux commissions et dont la
commission récemment créée qui a con
comme compétence développement durable
l'aménagement du territoire les
infrastructures de transport et
également donc une vision des énergies
renouvelables - je ne vais pas répéter
ce qui a été dit mais je pense que tous
mes collègues ici présents s'interroge
sur ce grand jeu qu'on constitue
désenclavement numérique du territoire
et là dessus je crois que certain nombre
de spécialistes qui sont ici présents
parmi mes collègues manquerons pas de
vous amener dans vos retranchements en
tout cas je l'espère puisque nous devons
nous devons être à ce rendez vous qui
est très important pour notre pays
et puis donc je voudrais présenter la
première question puisque je viens de
rencontrer le président de la ratp
et donc si mes collègues me le
permettent je poserai la première
question donc de ce cette rencontre que
nous pouvons ouvrir si vous voulez bien
en vous donnant tout de suite la parole
merci messieurs les présidents et merci
de votre invitation à venir m'exprimer
devant vous ce matin surtout à répondre
aussi de répondre en tout cas car vos
interrogations sur le secteur et sur
l'entreprise que j'ai l'honneur de
diriger depuis un peu plus de deux ans
je vous propose de faire une
introduction courte parce que je crois
que l'intérêt c'est surtout garder le
maximum de temps pour pour c est pour
ces échanges
j'aurais peut-être évoqué tout de suite
naturellement on pourra y revenir si
vous souhaitez sur la panne que nous
avons connues
pascal dernière pour dire que certes
elle montre combien les sociétés
d'aujourd'hui c'était contemporaine
complexe dépendent des réseaux vous avez
raison monsieur le président de dire de
tous les réseaux notamment des réseaux
de communication je pense qu'il ya de
quoi être réfléchir sur nos vies
personnelles et professionnelles la
façon dont on est même aujourd'hui
et au fond ce que cet accident
car c'est un accident qui s'est produit
un accident logiciel mais un accident ce
que cet accident monde sait que même
pour le principal opérateur celui qui
investit de plus dans les réseaux depuis
20 ans et notamment d'un réseau mobile
celui qui dispose du réseau le plus
étendu le plus performant tel qu'il a
été mesurée encore récemment et bien le
risque zéro n'existe pas
on a vu d'ailleurs quelques jours après
que un des principaux réseaux anglais
celui de o2 a connu à peu près le même
type de problème et a eu 24 heures
d'interruption de service
il ya eu deux jours de black out complet
en norvège il ya quelques mois tous les
grands réseaux américains ont connu des
problèmes de ce type et ça doit nous
amener sans doute à rester modeste face
à haas ce qu'est la gestion d'un système
aussi complexe qu'un réseau qu'un réseau
mobile et en même temps nous ce que nous
souhaitons surtout c'est tirer toutes
les conséquences d'avoir comprendre
exactement ce qui s'est passé et tirer
toutes les conséquences aussi de cette
expérience douloureuse pour nos clients
d'abord et pour nous aussi de façon est
d'abord plus performant si jamais on
rencontre à nouveau un problème de ce
type à dieu ne plaise et en particulier
mettre beaucoup moins de temps pour
établir les services que ça a été le cas
vendredi 6 juillet et puis naturellement
tout faire aussi pour que ça ne se
reproduise pas sur les causes techniques
de la panne vous savez c'est un problème
qui est survenu lors d'une mise à jour
logicielle sur un équipement qui
constituent ce qu'on appelle le coeur de
réseau et qui gère en fait d'aller
roquettes de localisation des abonnés
qui permet en fait c'est tout à fait
essentiel de savoir où sont les
utilisateurs de des téléphones mobiles
quels sont leurs droits aussi et donc et
qui est absolument critique
voilà donc on pourra y revenir si vous
le souhaitez mais jacques à ce stade
nous les conséquences qu'on en tire
outre les audits qu'on a engagés
naturellement avec dont on attend encore
les résultats c'est que on a
certainement des progrès à faire en ce
qui concerne non pas la réactivité de
l'entreprise qui a été très fort très
grande
on a pu mobiliser beaucoup d' équipe
tout de suite et je crois que vraiment
une fois de plus ce groupe a montré
aussi son engagement et et je dirais
quand même son sa compétence aussi dans
les moyens qu'elle a pu aligner très
rapidement pour remédier au problème
mais en même temps il ya des
conséquences en tirer sur les procédures
sur les processus de toute nature
lorsqu'il ya une crise comme çà de là je
rappelle quand même que forte
heureusement ça reste tout à fait
exceptionnelle puisque la dernière fois
qu'on a eu un problème un peu équivalent
c'était en 2004
il ya donc huit ans et un moment où le
téléphone mobile n'avait pas notamment
l'internet mobile d'ailleurs aussi toute
l'importance qu'il a aujourd'hui
si vous me le permettez ce que je
voulais très rapidement ccc dressés ou
rappeler les quelques grandes lignes de
du paysage je veux faire sans quelques
minutes est également caractérisé un peu
ce qui me semble être les forces du
groupe que je dirige face à cette donne
le secteur des télécoms en europe
il faut quand même le rappeler est un
secteur qui a considérablement contribué
à l'investissement et à l'emploi
d'ailleurs depuis une vingtaine d'années
et je souhaite redire devant vous que
france télécom le groupe ans et comme
orange c'est encore aujourd'hui près de
3 milliards d'euros d'investissements
chaque année en france à nous seuls nous
représentons parce que 2 % de
l'investissement industriel en france
c'est un peu plus de cent mille salariés
dont encore soixante mille
fonctionnaires sous statut c'est 3500
ingénieurs et techniciens dans la
recherche et d'innovation en france ça a
été au long des trois dernières années
10 mille recrutement en tout en 2000
dix ans 12 est donc un effort je crois
sans précédent et quand on élargit un
petit peu cette image aux opérateurs
historiques européens
france télécom deutsche telekom auquel
vous avez fait allusion telefonica et
telecom italia donc être les quatre
grands opérateurs historiques
nous représentons nou camp nou 4 800
mille salariés dans le monde
huit cent mille salariés et 1 milliard
de clients et nous investissons en 4 30
milliards d'euros par an dans l'ensemble
donc que chacun mesure est quand même
encore le poids économique de ce secteur
qui quand même tout à fait essentiel
dans nos pays notre pays et en europe
il se trouve que ce secteur aujourd'hui
et je crois qu'il faut dire très très
simplement et très directement et est en
danger il est en danger il est affaibli
très affaiblie par les 20 ans qui
viennent de s'écouler et et en
particulier par les orientations de fond
qui ont marqué la régulation du secteur
depuis l'ouverture à la concurrence du
secteur des télécoms et qui a abouti à
une situation qui je crois aujourd'hui
peut être considérée comme préoccupante
qui est caractérisée par le fait que
l'industrie est extrêmement fragmenté
vous le savez en europe pour 450
millions d'habitants et de clients il ya
une centaine d'opérateurs actifs à
comparer à 4 aux états unis trois en
chine pour un peu plus d'un milliard de
clients et donc cette fragmentation est
aujourd'hui un vrai problème
il y a eu je dirais une pression
réglementaire qui a été qui a été
constante au cours de ses 20 dans
l'année je vous donne juste un chiffre
le groupe france télécom-orange perd
chaque année le 1er janvier sans rien
faire uniquement du fait des redditions
réglementaire 1 milliard d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires et à peu près 300 350
millions d'euros de marge donc de
ressources de richesses qui sont autant
de moyens que nous n'avons pas pour pour
investir du côté fiscal
le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que ce
secteur a été considérée comme une vache
à lait continuellement depuis des années
je parie ci multiplie les exemples mais
malheureusement on a bien souvent vu
lorsqu'apparaissent et telle ou telle
idée ou tel ou tel besoin
l'idée d'après c'était de mettre une
taxe sur les télécoms soit sur les
faillites soit sur autre chose mais met
clairement cette image finalement d'un
secteur protégé entre guillemets
protégés de quoi on va on va y venir et
et dans lequel finalement on pouvait
continuer à puiser indéfiniment puisque
ballet résultat paraissait toujours
assez confortable a abouti à une
situation je crois qu'ils étaient
aujourd'hui relativement critique est
donc le résultat c'est qu'on a des
opérateurs qui sont affaiblis qu'ils
deviennent des cibles
il ya dans l'actualité récente un
événement qui doit faire réfléchir tout
le monde sait ce qui se passe sur
l'opérateur historique néerlandais kpn
qui est aujourd'hui l'objet d'une offre
hostile de la part d'un des grands
acteurs émergent sud américain et quand
vous regardez la valeur la valorisation
boursière valeur de marché des cinq
principaux opérateurs historiques
européens les quatre que j'ai mentionné
les fameux 810 savaria maire de clients
plus capé m vous arrivez un total
aujourd'hui qui n'est même pas la moitié
de la seule valeur d'apple l'entreprise
apple américaine vaut plus de deux fois
plus que les cinq opérateurs historiques
européens qui représentent à eux cinq
près d'un million de salariés
voilà donc eux nous sommes des géants
aux pieds d'argile
nous sommes des géants aux pieds
d'argile et si vous prenez le cas de
français comme orange aujourd'hui la
valeur boursière de france
télécom-orange est inférieure au montant
de ses fonds propres est inférieure au
montant de sa dette
et cette situation arrive au moment où
par ailleurs on doit faire face à une
explosion des usages donc on ne peut que
se réjouir puisque on a beaucoup
encouragé nous les premiers d'ailleurs
vous connaissez les chiffres le trafic
des données sur les réseaux mobiles x 68
dans les cinq dernières années et on
attend encore une multiplication par 6
ou 7 d'ici à 2015 tout ceci est
naturellement nécessite des
investissements énormes pour pouvoir
l'accompagner
tout le monde chante aujourd'hui la
révolution numérique l'économie
numérique les promesses de créations
d'emplois dans tous les secteurs du au
numérique tout ceci ne pourra pas se
faire s'il n'y a pas des opérateurs
suffisamment fort pour pouvoir investir
dans les réseaux c'est quand même je
dirais une réalité absolument basique
qu'il faut rappeler et qui commence tout
de même à provoquer une certaine prise
de conscience je dirais chez les
décideurs de tous les niveaux ce soit au
niveau national ou au niveau européen
j'insiste beaucoup quand même sur la
particularité européenne de cette
situation car lorsque vous allez en
dehors d'europe
vous voyez que les grands opérateurs
télécoms ne sont pas du tout dans une
situation que chez nous les américains
sont très puissants m'a parlé des sites
et des chinois qui sont clairement dans
un environnement système qui s'est
profondément différent et puis les
grands acteurs du monde des télécoms
d'aujourd'hui ils ce sont les acteurs
des pays émergents donc il ya vraiment
une particularité européenne qui vient
d'un choix politique un choix de société
très profond car était de construire une
europe des consommateurs et ça vous
l'avez dit je crois que c'est une vérité
qu'on mesure chaque jour un peu plus
dans tous les domaines d'ailleurs de
l'activité économique de l'industrie et
des services
nous avons construit tous autant que
nous sommes peut-être parfois un peu a
volontairement un grand marché de 450
millions de consommateurs qui ne
cherchent finalement qu'à baisser le
prix de ce qu'ils achètent que ce soit
des produits ou des services
considérant que tout ce qu'il ya
derrière qui produit qui qui fabrique
les produits qui
propose ses services dès que les
questions d'emploi les questions
d'investissement les questions de
recherche et d'innovation finalement
sont un peu secondaire par rapport à cet
objectif prioritaire qui est de trouver
des biens des services aux prix les plus
bas pour les consommateurs européens
en france on a par ailleurs une
situation qui et je dirai encore
particulière pour à ce tableau général
dans le mobile puisque il a été décidé
en france d'introduire un 4ème opérateur
de la téléphonie mobile
je veux pas ici refaire va certainement
parler comme dirait un célèbre
commentateur sportif le match parce que
nous prenons ça comme une donnée on peut
quand même pas manqué de s'interroger au
moins sur un point qui est le le le
je dirais le le contre ce cycle
peut-être le contresens de cette
décision au moment où elle a été prise
nous sommes quand même le seul pays le
seul grand marché mature aujourd'hui à
avoir pris cette décision là dans cette
période récente
il ya certes des pays où il ya quatre
voire même cinq opérateurs mais ils ont
été introduits il ya dix ans c'est à
dire à un moment où le marché d'abord
encore une croissance spontanée
tout le monde sait qu'aujourd'hui ce
n'est plus le cas et puis en plus c'est
ça surtout qu'il faut dire c'est que
partout en europe on voit aujourd'hui un
mouvement de consolidation qui se
dessine avec une réduction du nombre
d'opérateurs et c'est précisément à ce
moment là que la france a chois a décidé
elle de faire le chemin inverse
c'est-à-dire d'introduire un nous donc
je crois qu'on n'a pas fini quand même
de payer les conséquences de toutes
sortes d'ailleurs 2
ce décalage de phase par rapport à cette
arrivée du quatrième entrant mais
certainement on en reparlera je
terminerai en disant que cette
introduction en disant que je crois que
il ya aujourd'hui une prise de
conscience qui se dessine auprès de de
pas mal de décideurs en europe sur le
fait qu'il faut changer un peu la proche
de ce secteur
arrêtez de voir ces opérateurs et
notamment les opérateurs historiques
comme je dirais des entreprises dont la
santé même la pérennité d'ailleurs et
d'assurer pour l'éternité
aujourd'hui dans l'économie mondiale
telle qu'elle est aujourd'hui et dans
laquelle nous vivons
aucune situation et pérenne aucune et je
crois que au niveau européen
il ya eu récemment et je crois qu'on ya
beaucoup contribué
nous les opérateurs et votre serviteur
j'ai aussi apporter ma contribution à
expliquer en quoi les réalités
auxquelles nous faisons face aujourd'hui
doit conduire l'europe à concevoir sa
régulation de façon différente
il ya eu il ya quelques jours
l'annoncent par la commissaire
européenne mme anne creuse d'un
proposition d'un package de
recommandations sur la réglementation
qui est quand même un virage à 180
degrés par rapport à ce qu'on a connu
qui passe notamment par la stabilisation
des prix d'accès au réseau cuivre en
considérant tout simplement qu' on peut
pas demander aux opérateurs aux
opérateurs historiques d'investir dans
les réseaux du futur et de la fibre si
en même temps on continue
continuellement je dirais à baisser
leurs ressources notamment par par la
baisse des prix d'accès au réseau cuivre
et qui doit y avoir une forme de donnant
donnant entre une forme de stabilisation
de moratoire sur les prix d'accès aux
réseaux historiques
il ya naturellement des plans
d'investissement
dans les réseaux du futur donc ça je
pense que c'est un c'est un premier
changement qui tout à fait majeur j'ai
eu l'occasion d'en parler avec le
président de l'arcep
encore récemment kim a indiqué qu'il
accueillait favorablement cette
réorientation et que lui-même pour la
sep et pour la france en tout cas était
tout à fait disposé préparer en tirer
tout lé toutes les conséquences ici tout
est bon donc il ya une prise de
conscience et dans ce paysage le groupe
français est comme orange
je veux le dire ici est un groupe qui
par le travail qu'il a fait ces
dernières années et solide des efforts
il est solide et fort j'ai dit qu'on
était tous je dirais on a tous été
impactés par ce qui s'est passé ces
vingt dernières années mais quand je
regarde la scène européenne je pense
qu'on peut tous se réjouir d'avoir un
une grande société en france qui est
quand même la propriété des français
aussi puisque n'oublions pas que l'état
a encore presque 27% du capital qui est
forte elle est forte d'abord parce
qu'elle a une situation financière qui a
été restauré après la crise qu'on a
connus au début des années 2000 vous en
souvenez tout le travail de tous nos
salariés est aussi d'ailleurs l'effort
collectif puisque l'état a été première
en capitaliser l'entreprise à ce
moment-là nous permet aujourd'hui
d'avoir une situation qui est saine
on a une dette qui est maîtrisé et on a
des conditions d'accès aux marchés
financiers qui sont corrects et même si
le cours de l'action est aujourd'hui un
niveau qui ne reflète pas à mon avis la
valeur de ce groupe on a quand même un
bilan une cession qui est saine et donc
des moyens
les capacités d'investissement qui sont
qui sont intactes nous faisons face à
nos différentes contraintes
je pense notamment la sélection
française on y reviendra certainement
avec pragmatisme avec beaucoup
d'engagement et en considérant que ce
n'est pas l'emploi en france qui doit
servir de variable d'ajustement
bon on a une situation d'emploi qui est
différente de celle des autres
opérateurs aussi parce que le mobile en
france ne représente que à peu près 25%
du chiffre d'affaires du groupe
donc je parlais ici faire d'eux de
comparaison avec les autres acteurs qui
sont pas dans la même situation et de
donner de leçons certainement pas mais
en tout cas c'est vrai que il ya des
adaptations à faire c'est une évidence
mais en même temps ces adaptations on
essaie de les faire dans le respect
aussi de nos engagements en matière
d'emploi
c'est évident qu'on refera moins dans
les années qui viennent que ça a été le
cas notamment dans les deux ou trois
dernières années mais en même temps il
n'y a pas de projet de réduction
d'effectifs de plaindre
a fortiori de plan social dans le groupe
je le redis avec avec clarté tout notre
objectif est de consacrer le maximum de
ressources à l'investissement à
l'investissement dans les réseaux fixes
c'est le programme de la fibre dont vous
connaissez les grandes lignes avec une
première étape d'ici à 2015 avec
l'objectif de démarrer le déploiement de
la fibre dans 3600 communes et crois
pouvoir dire mais on va beaucoup en
parler je suppose que ça se passe
aujourd'hui des choses et que et qu'on a
vraiment commencé engagé et on monte en
puissance sur ce programme fibre cette
année en 2012 le montant des
investissements du groupe sur la fibre
représentera à peu près le double de ce
qu'on a fait l'année en 2011 et on va
augmenter encore en 2013 donc on est
clairement en phase de montée en
puissance quelles que soient les
difficultés qu'ont que nous rencontrons
par ailleurs sur les sur les marchés du
mobile et n'avons absolument pas
l'intention de remettre en cause ce
programme de la film je veux ici bien
appelez l'attention des responsables que
vous êtes des élus de la nation sur le
fait qu' il ya un lien entre tout ça
c'est à dire que particulier la
situation du mobile a évidemment un
impact extrêmement forts sur le dossier
de la fibre
pourquoi parce que ce sont les mêmes
opérateurs qui sont des deux côtés donc
l' affaiblissement important qui est
liée à la rentrée du quatrième entrant
des grands les opérateurs français va
immanquablement avoir des conséquences
sur le sur la fibre car ce sont encore
une fois les mêmes on peut pas avoir une
politique visant à augmenter la
concurrence et donc baisser le niveau
des ressources des opérateurs mobiles en
six ans bah oui mais attendez il ya la
fibre aussi à financer ce sont les mêmes
et donc forcément il ya la nécessité
d'avoir une forme de cohérence entre
tous les aspects de du sujet telecom qui
n'a peut-être pas été toujours à
l'oeuvre
du côté des investissements et je
termine par là la priorité pour nous
elle est aussi d'accélérer le
déploiement de la 4g c'est à dire de la
nouvelle génération de téléphonie mobile
qui va nous permettre je dirais de
conforter politique de différenciation
par la qualité des réseaux pour nous qui
peut être aussi d'ailleurs un des
éléments de réponse à la fracture
numérique
car la firme ne sera pas la solution
unique d'arrivée de pavant du très haut
débit dans ce pays et donc la 4g fera
pourra faire partie aussi dans un
certain nombre d'endroits des moyens de
traiter c'est l'axé où l'égalité de
l'accès au très haut débit
et nous nous avons décidé d'accélérer
le déploiement de la 4g j'ai inauguré il
ya quelques jours le premier réseau 4g
réel à marseille à marseille un peu plus
de la moitié aujourd'hui des sites
radios à marseille qui sont 4g lte et eu
pour l'instant pas grand monde ne pas en
profiter puisqu'il n'y a pas tellement
de terminaux et très peu de terminaux
qui permet de le faire mais dès le mois
de septembre on va avoir déjà une gamme
de terminaux et tout ceci va pas d assez
rapidement donc orange france télécom
france télécom-orange que vous voulez
pour un jour simplifiée un peu sa est un
groupe qui est lucide face à son
environnement qui essaient de faire
passer quelques messages forts notamment
partie rencontre des décideurs et j'ai
cette opportunité là ce matin sur les
questions de réglementation sur les
choix qui sont faits dans ce secteur qui
est absolument stratégique
c'est un groupe et un opérateur mondial
c'est le seul opérateur d'ailleurs
mondiale dans des télécoms français les
autres opérateurs qui sont présents sur
marché français ne sont pratiquement
qu'en france
en tout cas en tant que tel qu'en france
donc mesureront aussi je crois la chance
collective que nous avons d'avoir un
groupe comme comme celui là on est
présent dans 35 pays
nous sommes un début une des plus
grandes entreprises françaises en
afrique et au moyen-orient
nous avons plus de clients en egypte
qu'en france nous sommes dans des pays
qui se représentent des enjeux aussi
diplomatique politique et économique
très important pour la france comme
l'irak l'egypte j'en ai parlé tous les
pays du maghreb l'afrique francophone
et puis tous les grands pays européens
et je crois que au fond ce qui nous
anime
eh bien c'est la volonté de faire de cet
outil
une entreprise qui soit utile pour les
français en france et donc ça c'est la
situation de la france et notamment les
poissons de l'emploi qui est tout à fait
critiquent le déploiement du très haut
débit en france
on va en parler mais au delà aussi le
rayonnement de cette entreprise sur la
scène internationale par ses
investissements par son son
développement et aussi par ses efforts
d'innovation
merci monsieur le président avant de
donner la parole à mon collègue raymond
vall qui a une question et qui avait
présenté la première question je vous
rappelle mes chers collègues que pour le
moment j'en suis à 14 demandes de prise
de parole je vous rappelle ce qui s'est
passé hier est la durée de l'audition de
madame bateau ce que je souhaiterais
c'est que pas plus de deux minutes par
intervenant ce que sinon on va vous
couper parce que c'est pas possible
de tenir avant midi 12h15 je vous
demande d'être concis ce qui changera le
comportement de certains j'ai des noms
et donc raymond vall dû à la parole pour
deux minutes
c'est sous la contrainte monsieur le
président tout cas jours nous remercions
de cette introduction
alors moi c'est très simple et parler de
capacité d'investissement intacte vous
ai parlé de similitudes entre les deux
prestations téléphoniques et haut débit
le président dont pierre mongin m à vous
propose de conquérir 10 millions
d'usagers par jour dans le métro
il s'étonne que finalement alors qu'elle
sait faire a déjà signé que bouygues va
signer dans les huit jours
il n'est pas de propositions nous votre
société concernant donc l'utilisation
des services de français comme d'un dans
les transports ratp parisienne qui
représente 10 millions de consommateurs
je vais essayer de faire de vagues de 7
pour simplifier le travail de réponse de
du président richard parce que si on met
14 avec le personne ne s'y retrouvera
donc je vous propose deux vagues de 7 et
donc michel teston pour deux minutes
maximum merci monsieur le président sur
le président de france télécom-orange
je me bornerai a évoqué deux sujets
premier sujet la situation de l'emploi
dans la filière téléphonie mobile je
rappelle brièvement nous avons eu un
débat je crois que c'était au printemps
2009 sur l'intérêt ou pas l'utiliser
d'autoriser un quatrième opérateur de
téléphonie mobile
j'avais dit à l'époque au nom du groupe
socialiste du sénat que je considérais
qu'il valait mieux demander aux trois
opérateurs existants de développer
davantage la couverture du territoire ce
n'est pas la solution qui a été retenue
aujourd'hui a des conséquences en termes
d'emploi deux opérateurs ont annoncé des
plans sociaux
vous venez de nous dire qu'il n'y en
aurait pas à france télécom orange
on aimerait en avoir la certitude
deuxième sujet la couverture numérique
du territoire
le plan national très haut débit fait
monsieur le président de france
télécom-orange la part très belle aux
opérateurs
et cantonne les collectivités locales
dans la couverture des zones les moins
denses ce que le gouvernement précédent
a appelé la zone 3 alors on va pas
pouvoir à mon avis continue comme ça il
faudra faire évoluer le plan national
très haut débit
nous allons y réfléchir très
soigneusement mais en attendant on
aimerait être certain que vous allez
pouvoir tenir les engagements que vous
avez pris tant en ce qui concerne le
fixe que le mobile c'est à dire la 4g
vous nous dire à l'instant que tel
serait le cas mais la montée en
puissance de vos investissements ne nous
rassure pas très bien monsieur moore l
exercice oui merci monsieur présent sur
sur le quatrième opérateur je
rappellerai que j'avais pris des
positions à peu près identique à celle
de michel teston région en indiquant qu
effectivement ce n'était pas le meilleur
moyen d'améliorer la couverture des
territoires que de 2,2 d'accorder
naissance un quatrième opérateur
je suis d'accord avec vous anime sur le
présent soit notion de vache à lait j'ai
également souvent dit qu on se servait
beaucoup trop des opérateurs comme de
vache à lait et que je préférerais qu'on
s'en sert un peu moins comme vache à
lait mais qu'on le remette un peu plus
d'obligations en termes de couverture du
territoire
c'est donc sur la couverture du
territoire j'aimerais vous poser trois
questions la première c'est sur le haut
débit parce qu'on a parlé de très haut
débit mais encore des territoires qui
n'ont même pas de haut débit vous avez
lancé en 2010 un programme triennal de
neutralisation des multiplexeurs qui
devait d'ici 2013 permettre d'améliorer
la couverture en haut débit de
territoire et faire en sorte selon vos
chiffres qu'il y ait 99% de la
population couverte en en adsl pour
cause d'économies j'ai appris au niveau
régional que ce programme était arrêté
ou interrompue vous avez démenti le fait
que ce têt que s'étaient interrompus ou
suspendus donc moi j'aimerais savoir si
vous êtes en mesure de confirmer que
comme vous l'aviez annoncé ce programme
triennal se terminera bien en 2013 j'ai
un petit doute dans la mesure où
monsieur louette m'a écrit qu'au 1er
mars 2012
un tiers du programme avaient été
réalisés donc si on a fait un tir en
deux ans je suis pas sûr qu'on a à faire
deux tiers en un an
deuxième question sûre sur le très haut
débit
vous avez annoncé vous venez de parler
d'une montée en puissance de vos
investissements
comment se fait-il alors s'il ya une
montée en puissance de vos
investissements que dans le même temps
le cycab elle qui l'organisme des
professions qui déploie la fibre pour
faire simple on une baisse de leur
carnet de commandes de 50% et donc sept
éléments confortent les doutes qu un
certain nombre d'observateurs y compris
au niveau de l'état actionnaire des
doutes qu un certain nombre
d'observateurs ont quant à la réalité de
vos observations
et puis troisième question puisque le
président me presse vous vous êtes vrais
très manifeste vous allez largement
manifester votre désaccord avec la
proposition de loi qui a été adoptée au
sénat et notamment sur le fait que nous
avons souhaité qu'il y ait une
contractualisation des engagements pris
par les opérateurs vis-à-vis des
collectivités et j'aimerais savoir ce
qui vous gêne dans le fait qu'un
engagement car si monsieur michel ne
soit pas seulement bien carole da verbal
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président vous avez évoqué la question
effectivement du déploiement de la fibre
nous savons bien que le point qui fâche
pour nous ce sont les zones périurbaines
ou rurales où on considère qu'il n'y a
pas assez de clients pour autant un
certain nombre de collectivités ont
essayé chaque fois qu'elle faisait des
travaux de mettre des gaines on sait que
c'est ce qui coûte le plus cher
est ce que il est prévu d'avoir une
attention particulière en direction de
ces communes quelle que soit leur taille
quelle que soit leur ruralité est ce
qu'il y a un regard particulier sur cet
aspect là des choses
ma deuxième question est plus
anecdotique savez vous pourquoi vous
avez perdu
les contrats des ministères et du sénat
en téléphonie notre éminent collègue
delamontagne pierre hérisson pour une
fois qu'il est pas au téléphone
c'est un peu diesel mon système
je ne n'avais pas réalisé que c'était
moi d'éminents collègues excusez moi de
te poser simplement quelques mots dans
l'est dans les deux minutes
monsieur le président de france
télécom-orange pour dire d'abord former
un voeu pour que ya un choix qu'il soit
fait entre france télécom et orange le
plus rapidement possible ça simplifiera
le langage l'écriture et ça permettra de
gagner du temps sur le l'accident
logicielle globale et est ce que vous
envisagez à très court terme des mesures
de sécurité complémentaires ne serait ce
que pour à l'adresse de ceux qui
pourraient avoir des mauvaises pensées
et des actes terroristes ou des actes de
malveillance je crois qu'il ya là une
vraie question qui se pose et qui
méritent de voir une réaction très
rapide donc en est-il sur le l'ensemble
du développement du réseau allons nous
avons les uns les autres d approche un
peu différente on le voit bien à travers
ce qui est dit pour pour l' approche qui
est fait 30 au déploiement de réseaux
moi je dirais compatibilité
complémentarité mutualisation alors
compatibilité c'est de voir comment les
moyens techniques et technologiques
peuvent être complémentaires
je prendre un exemple pour ça est ce
qu'on peut imaginer et on en parle
relativement peu à mon avis de manière
insuffisante
pourquoi ne pas utiliser de la fibre
optique les réseaux et le développement
de la fibre optique pour imaginer qu'à
un moment donné on ressent localement et
qu'on fait de la 4g mais qui a une
complémentarité des moyens techniques
entre les deux que pensez vous de cette
de cette idée de cette avancée en ce qui
concerne la mutualisation évidemment il
s'agit des moyens mais
faut-il faire payer les consommateurs au
faut-il faire payer des usagers clients
dans les deux cas ce sont souvent les
mêmes mais pas tout à fait mais en tout
cas je serais tenté de dire pour
terminer monsieur le président que nous
avons à faire nous aussi une réflexion
approfondie parce que le pouvoir
législatif c'est nous le pouvoir
réglementaire
c'est quelque part l'état et que les
opérateurs mériterait peut-être d'avoir
une plus grande transparence et de plus
grandes précisions sur le sud le pdj
cela ti fait sur l'aspect réglementaire
merci monsieur hérisson vous avez
utilisé le crédit de même didier qui est
généreuse monsieur rome
oui monsieur le président je me félicite
de la volonté de france télécom
renouveler d'avoir une politique
volontariste en matière d'atteinte de
l'objectif de la lisa très haut débit de
notre territoire
je me félicite également vous l'avez
réaffirmé du besoin de la nation d'avoir
un opérateur fort sur la scène
internationale j'aurai trois questions
précises à vous poser manifestant ainsi
l'inquiétude des collectivités
territoriales que je représente ici par
ailleurs au titre d'autres fonctions en
2010 vous avez dévoilé votre plan
conquêtes 2015 objectif 10000 prise
devait être fibrés aujourd'hui l'arcep
tu viens de donner les chiffres
nous en sommes à 1 million 580000 tout
opérateur confondu
on voit bien la distance qui reste à
parcourir pour atteindre l'objectif
d'ici 2015 alors j'aimerais connaître
quels sont vos jalons prévisionnel fin
2012 fin 2013 2014 pour permettre
d'atteindre cet objectif
d'autre part je voudrais connaître quel
est le montant du budget puisque vous
avez épistolaire mans et physiquement
fait état de votre volonté de travailler
plus demain que par le passé avec des
collectivités territoriales
quels sont les moyens et le montant des
budgets que france télécom va dégager
d'ici 2015 pourquoi investir sur les
réseaux d'initiative publique mais aussi
et surtout de mieux
utilisé pour ce qui existe et enfin
êtes-vous prêts dès maintenant dans le
droit fil de la sujétion vient nous
faire moi quoi les guérit sont entrés en
discussions avec les départements et
régions qui porte les schémas directeurs
territoriaux d'aménagement numérique sur
la couverture priori de cette zone
prioritaire au titre de la 4g afin de
leur donner une visibilité et de créer
des problématiques comme les réseaux de
collecte qui doivent accompagner ce
passage à la 4g voilà trois questions
précises au delà de considérations plus
générales que nous aurons l'occasion de
vous re formulé monsieur le président de
parole dans la première vague
bruno retailleau quatre sujets en deux
minutes premier sujet sur le bug est une
défaillance humaine
et puis ensuite quel est le coût pour le
groupe à ce que vous pouvez nous donner
un ordre d'idée sur le 4e opérateur est
ce que vous pensez nous avons reçu d'un
opérateur alternatif pour certains
d'entre nous une lettre pensez vous
étendre à la 4g
l'accord d'itinérance que vous avez pris
avec cet opérateur sur la 3g 3e
troisième point concerne des sur la
fibre je crois que les inquiétudes
l'inquiétude principale des
collectivités se concentre sur les zones
amis dans quelle mesure avec quels
moyens selon quelles modalités
vous pouvez nous donner un certain
nombre de d'assurance sur les
déploiements en temps et en heure prévue
j'ajoute d'ailleurs là-dessus puisque
les uns et les autres parlent et de
cohérence c'est que comme ce que
j'entends sur les dividendes
actuellement j'attends avec grande
impatience le comportement de l'état
vis-à-vis du dividende français l'école
pour l'exercice ce prochain puisque
l'état a maintenu cette année ce montant
de dividende et et enfin j'ai noté avec
vous le virage à 180° de neelie kros
c'est un virage très important
j'ai noté aussi ce qu'elle disait sur le
cuivre
c'est important de le rappeler y compris
dans cette enceinte là parce que je 60
ans nous avons eu des approches un petit
peu différente
ce qu'elle dit aussi sur la régulation
qui ne sera pas orienté rallye coup sûr
sur la fibre optique donc je pense que
ça va sécuriser le cadre de vos
investissements
un mot michel boyon va partir bientôt du
csa et en partant
également il se déclare prêt à fusionner
le csa et l'arcep les deux régulateurs
qu'est ce que vous en pensez à titre de
premier grand opérateur télécoms
français au premier impensable dernière
question je l'évoquais déjà dans
d'autres circonstances fusion entre
l'arcep et le csa
avec la convergence de technologies je
vois pas très bien pourquoi il y aurait
deux organismes vous connaissez aussi
mon sentiment sur les autorités dites
indépendantes le ciel président feu
volonté si j'ose dire par rapport aux
réponses bien manger prendre si vous
voulez bien les questions dans lorsque
j'essayais des notes à peu près dans
l'eau pour le sujet ratp d'abord je vous
confirme prône est en discussion
toujours avec la ratp et que notre
attention est d'arriver à un accord avec
la ratp
donc je mange un dont on connaît
l'énergie laquelle il aborde tous les
sujets d'ailleurs mais celui là aussi
peut être rassuré là dessus on n'a pas
l'intention de parti qu'est la politique
de la chaise vide
bon c'est vrai qu'il a fallu un petit
peu de temps pour qu'on se comprenne je
dirais entre les opérateurs et de la
ratp sur ce sujet du déploiement d'un
réseau sur lens sur le métro
enfin sur le parce que comme tout sujet
s'agissant des entreprises qui ont des
obligations de résultats et donc qui
regardent la rentabilité d'un
investissement
d'ailleurs atp attendait un certain
nombre de retombées positives y compris
financières de cette affaire les
opérateurs regardent ça certes en
prenant en compte l'intérêt des usagers
mais aussi en regardant
leurs sous parce que c'est bien investir
dans le métro mais aussi il faut
investir partout dans les territoires
etc
il faut déployer la 4g il faut faire la
fibre donc tous ces investissements ils
doivent être regardées aussi en fonction
de leurs conditions financières de
rentabilité et d'où les fédérés les
discussions qui se sont engagés avec la
ratp dont j'ai bon espoir qu'elles
aboutissent rapidement je pense qu'on
sera présent sur ce sujet et le dernier
mot là dessus il ya eu quand même un une
évolution importante dans la proche de
la ratp sur ce sujet je connais pas et
ce qu'ils cherchaient c'était une forme
d'exclusivité gars est un opérateur qui
me fasse tout l'investissement sur
l'ensemble de la de l'infrastructure
gérée par la ratp
cette approche honnêtement n'était pas
économiquement possible et donc il a dû
changer son fusil d épaule
et si la raison pour laquelle
aujourd'hui tous les opérateurs
devraient que vous pour rejoindre le
sujet nous en bray alors sur les emplois
dans la filière mobile
moi je partirai d'un constat de bon sens
on a introduit un quatrième opérateur en
france pour essentiellement pour rendre
du pouvoir d'achat c'est ce que j'ai
beaucoup entendu aux usages et aux
consommateurs
et d'ailleurs le quatrième entrant en
question s'est pas privé de prendre ses
oripeaux du robin des bois qui va rendre
de l'argent aux consommateurs il est
même parlé d'ailleurs d'un montant de
l'ordre de 5,6 humaine entendu 7
milliards d'euros de valeur qu'elle est
tendue aux consommateurs à partir de là
si vous voulez pour les opérateurs qui
aujourd'hui sont sur ce marché il ya
deux solutions soit ce sont des
entreprises particulièrement mal gérée
particulièrement improductives
particulièrement dispendieuse et à ce
moment là ils n'auront pas de mal à
s'adapter et donc finalement 6 ou 7
milliards d'euros en moins pour elle
c'est pas c'est pas gênant soit on admet
le fait que quand même malgré tout
malgré beaucoup d'insuffisances ces
entreprises sont quand même à peu près
normalement gérer un
martin bouygues est un entrepreneur est
une famille d'entrepreneurs d'ailleurs
qui a quand même faire certain nombre de
choses dans ce pays depuis des décennies
donc bon quant à france télécom je crois
que c'est aussi une entreprise qui
essaie de respecter un certain nombre de
règles et de critères et à partir de là
personne ne pouvait imaginer qu'un
transfert de valeurs aussi un massif ne
pouvez pas avoir des conséquences alors
naturellement que savard des
conséquences avoir des conséquences sur
eux je dirais toutes les parties
prenantes de l'entreprise certes sur les
actionnaires et donc oui on va devoir
baisser le dividende que nous versons à
nos actionnaires y compris l'état ça on
a déjà annoncé des annonces dans ce sens
et on continuera à y travailler tout en
étant clair aussi sur le fait que nous
sommes une entreprise cotée
nous avons 30 milliards de tête et que
nous ne pouvons pas considérer que
les actionnaires en général sont
purement la variable d'ajustement de
tout le système parce que il ya une
continuité dans tout ça et on peut pas
s'adresser à une partie des marchés de
capitaux en demandant de la dette et
faire un bras d'honneur si vous me
passez l'expression aux mêmes personnes
qui investissent dans le capital de nos
entreprises donc il faut de la cohérence
dans cette stratégie est donc on peut
pas faire du tout au rien mais en même
temps c'est clair qu'on va baisser le
dividende comme on a déjà commencé à le
faire
mais au-delà de ça naturellement il
faudra bien que pour pouvoir rétablir
les équilibres économiques de nos
entreprises qui ont été très fortement
impacté par cette arrivée du quatrième
entrant qui est un modèle économique
différent et qui va entraîner
on l'a dit des baisses de prix très
importantes sur le marché français qui
va devenir très rapidement je pense à
des marchés européens où les prix du
téléphone mobile sont les plus bas car
c'est ça qui va se passer et donc les
marges des opérateurs les plus basses
naturellement ça aura des conséquences
voilà donc moi je vais pas parler pour
les autres qui ont commencé à évoquer
des sujets ça a été l'objet vous le
savez peut-être d'une table ronde qui a
eu lieu hier matin avec lisieux
redressement productif et à m'isoler de
l'économie numérique
on a fait part sans fard je dirais delà
de la situation
je crois que le gouvernement a
l'intention de regarder si y'a pas un
certain nombre de mesures on peut
envisager pour limiter je dirais cet
impact sur l'emploi
on va pas faire le catalogue mais c'est
vrai quand même que depuis un certain
nombre d'années dans ce secteur tout a
été fait pour augmenter les droits des
consommateurs y compris parfois en
allant jusqu'à l'absurde
je vous prends juste un exemple je vous
prendre juste un exemple l'absurde
économique en tout cas pas pour le
consommateur mais l'absurde économique
je vous prends un exemple qui est la
question des durées d'engagement on sait
très bien que les consommateurs à ne pas
avoir des durées d'engagement sur le
contrat n'a pas attendu maintenant pour
le découvrir on le sait très bien
en même temps pourquoi ce qui est des
durées d'engagement parce qu'on propose
aussi un certain nombre de gens que ça
intéresse des terminaux qui ne souhaite
pas par ailleurs payé au prix lui sont
donc la durée d'engagement
elle est uniquement liée aux à la
nécessité pour satisfaire un besoin du
consommateur de subventionner ces
terminaux est donc d'étaler ce coup sûr
sur une certaine période
là dessus une envie qu'on a besoin la
durance voilà et dépend dépend de chacun
certainement en un 4ème entrant qui
arrive avec un modèle qui est lui fondé
sur la carte sim seulement et qui
considèrent que en tout cas qui a voulu
être présent sur cette partie du marché
et donc pas sur la partie subvention
d'une subvention du terminal et donc il
fait une percée en vendant uniquement
des cartes sim parallèlement à ça on a
des lois la loi chatel pour ne pas la
nommer qui a en a remis une louche
encore avec ses dispositions en donnant
la possibilité à aux anneaux à nos
clients finalement de réduire encore de
façon très substantielle le sait ces
durées d'engagement
il ya un moment où on arrive à annuler
par on n'arrive nulle part comment on
peut pas lutter sur un modèle de
subventions sans doute sans engagement
et si on nous explique que finalement
les opérateurs sortant dont 90% du
chiffre d'affaires est basé sur le
modèle de subventions ça a évolué et
changé c'est encore le cas eh bien on
rogne continuellement je dirais les
éléments qui sont critiques dans leur
modèle économique
on n'y arrive pas donc c'est juste un
exemple c'est pour dire qu' il n'y a pas
un sujet à sortir par rapport à d'autres
c'est il ya toute une série de domaines
on en a parlé avec le ministre hier qui
je crois il ya la facturation des hot
lines c'est la même chose il ya une
partie des services dont on peut
admettre qu'ils doivent être resté
gratuit l'assistance et il y en a
d'autres pour lesquels franchement
pourquoi qu'elle est calé le je dirais
le rationnel économique de considérer
que tout les hotlines navette gratuite
non c'est encore une ressource qu'on a
dont on prive aussi les opérateurs faut
pas s'étonner après que les dix
opérateurs à y délocaliser leurs centres
d'appels dans les pays à bas coûts voilà
donc moi je pense que là dessus il faut
qu'on reprenne tous ces éléments là et
qu'on fois ci
il n'y a pas des moyens et je crois
qu'il y en a qui permettent de réduire
en tout cas beaucoup l'impact sur
l'emploi
en tout cas pour ceux qui ont déjà
annoncé des plans dans ce centre ça
n'est pas le cas de france et comme je
l'aï dit nous n'avons pas de réductions
d'emplois pourquoi on en a pas parce que
notre équation d'emploi est différente
en france
je lui dis on ad'abord d'autres
activités que de mobiles et est par
ailleurs et à l'itinérance je vais
revenir qui est un qui a été clairement
alors je l'assumé pour moi un moyen je
dirais d'amortir l'impact économique du
quatrième entrant et donc de pouvoir
jurer gérer cette situation dans la
durée sans à-coups sans brutalité
excusez moi de le rappeler mais france
télécom est quand même particulièrement
placé pour savoir ce que la brutalité
des ajustements a pu causer dans sa
chair et dans son corps social ces
dernières années donc moi je considère
que mon premier devoir est que ça ne se
reproduise pas et donc de tout faire
pour que je dirais dans des décisions
qui sont pas faciles à prendre toujours
et les ignorants ça a été une décision
difficile
eh bien on prenne en compte aussi cette
variable là qui est tout simplement
celle des hommes et des femmes de
l'entreprise alors sur sur la couverture
très haut débit sujet qui a été
naturellement évoqué par beaucoup
d'entre vous d'abord moi j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion de le dire et je me rends
assez régulièrement sur le territoire
je comprends très bien l'impatience et
l'inquiétude d'ailleurs de beaucoup de
collectivités sur ce dossier pourquoi
parce que je crois que c'est ce que
disent tous les élus c'est devenu quand
même un sujet absolument essentiel dans
la vie de nos concitoyens et que c'est
un sujet qui est important pour
l'installation des jeunes ménages pour
les entreprises aussi évidemment et on
peut pas aujourd'hui parler de vie des
territoires je parle même pas de
revitalisation des territoires
s'il n'y a pas ça s'il n'ya pas le
le haut débit vous avez raison déjà pour
certaines zones et a fortiori pour
l'avenir le très haut débit donc croyez
bien que il ya aujourd'hui dans ce
groupe une équipe dirigeante les mots en
particulier qui ceux qui sont
parfaitement conscients de cette réalité
là et de la pression que ça que ça
exerce sur les élus parce que vous êtes
je crois interpellé continuellement par
vos administrés par des habitants des
nouveaux de vos circonscriptions sur ce
sujet ce qui est difficile dans ce
dossier c'est que on voit bien qu'il ya
pas de solution simple qui se dessine et
qui permettent à coup sûr je dirais et
en faisant l'économie d'une forme de
confiance entre les uns les autres
d'arriver au résultat
la solution simple qui aurait qu on
aurait pu imaginer gâtés en temps ça
aurait été de dire bah enfin un grand
emprunt d'état de 30 milliards d'euros
on prend la direction générale des
télécommunications avec telle qualité à
travailler à trente ans comme on a fait
finalement pour le téléphone dans les
années 70 et on déroule bon
malheureusement le monde a changé
malheureusement ou heureusement je ne
sais pas le monde a changé on n'est plus
du tout dans cette configuration là il
ya un secteur qui est ouvert à la
concurrence donc il ya un certain nombre
d'opérateurs qui sont en même temps
opérateurs mobiles comme je l'aï dit il
ya l'europe qui a dicté un certain
nombre de règles il ya le régulateur et
les collectivités aussi au mieux tout ça
donc la solution passera nécessairement
par je dirais un mix comme on dit dans
le jargon de solutions et et par une
relation de confiance qui doit pouvoir
s'établir et je sais que c'est difficile
et ça suppose certainement des
engagements et de la contractualisation
et ça c'est clair entre les uns et les
autres et entre les opérateurs et les
collectivités nous en ce qui nous
concerne c'est vraiment ce qu'on essaie
de faire c'est ce qu'on essaie de faire
d'une part en étant transparent sur nos
plans on a pris les engagements annoncés
des plans chiffrées vous l'avez rappelé
plan conquêtes 2015 je vais vous donner
faux pelure plus actualisé le plan
précis fibre avec l'objectif des 2 2
milliards d'ici à 2015 des 10 millions
de foyers adressable bon et des taux de
couverture donc on a pris des
engagements et par ailleurs on signe je
signe d'ailleurs régulièrement j'en ai
fait quand même un certain nombre ces
derniers mois des conventions avec des
grandes collectivités
j'ai signé une convention avec la région
bretagne gc 1 1 suivi avec la région
auvergne
j'en ai signé avec des départements on à
côte d'or avec des villes même à laval
et c'est donc on n'est pas du tout
hostile à une forme de
contractualisation dans des conventions
qui perdent dont le l'intérêt essentiel
d'ailleurs est de donner aux
collectivités la possibilité la faculté
de suivre précisément ce qu'on fait donc
on ne refuse pas du tout cette relation
qui me semble est une nécessité
clairement pour que l'on puisse avancer
dans cette confiance qui doit s'insérer
moi je vous redis très clairement que
nous n'avons pas de projet pas de plan
pas l'intention ou simplement de baisser
ou de sacrifier ou les diminuer les
ressources que nous mettons dans nos
investissements en france sur le haut et
le très haut débit dans les années qui
viennent
même si on doit je lui dis tout le monde
le sait on doit
gérer je dirais une contraction quand
même assez forte de nos ressources
puisque globalement la marge de nos
activités en france du fait du quatrième
entrant sur le mobile et d'autres
éléments
blio pense quand même que nous nous
avons aussi un peu comme la poste avec
le courrier un une source de revenus qui
baisse continuellement et qui est le
réseau fixe classique traditionnelle 1
donc on doit gérer aussi ce déclin plus
des effets du quatrième entrant donc ça
tout ça provoque une impact important et
une contraction continue je dirais de
nos ressources en france on y fait face
avec des plans aussi d'adaptation mais
en aucun cas c'est l'investissement qui
en fera les frais et d'ailleurs le
pourcentage du chiffre d'affaires
consacré à l'investissement du groupe
est en augmentation sensible depuis deux
ans on est passé d'un peu moins de 10% à
pratiquer à pratiquement 14 % cette
année et on va continuer à rester à des
niveaux à des niveaux relativement
élevés comment on fait pour régler cette
équation bas on le fait effectivement en
diminuant de voir leurs biens sont nos
actionnaires je lui dis et donc c'est
clair que le dividende que nous allons
payer à partir de l'année prochaine dès
cette année des ans sera en baisse assez
sensible et puis en faisant toute une
série d'efforts de productivité et de
performance tout en préservant l'emploi
et c'était quoi ce n'est pas simple à
gérer mais c'est ça la fait d'autres